yes so wave power is an immense source
of electricity of clean electricity
according to the world energy council
wave energy can actually produce twice
the amount of electricity that the world
produces now
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven
fund in silicon valley in partnership
with lumitec
and sponsored by hippo insurance touring
opposed labs
and hillel at stanford this story is
incredible from a near-death experience
as a child to making an impact that can
literally change the world
meet ina braverman co-founder and ceo of
eco-wave power ltd
ina founded eco-wave powered age of 24.
under her leadership the company
installed its first grid connected wave
energy array secured a significant
projects pipeline of 254 megawatts
and became the first israeli company to
ever list on nasdaq stockholm
she was recognized by wired magazine as
one of the females changing the world
by fast companies one of the world's
most creative people in business for
and is the winner of the united nations
global climate action award
bravo man welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
very well thank you how are you i'm
doing great thank you i'm excited to
talk all about electricity today and
your personal journey
and i'm going to let you talk about the
the fascinating details as much as you
feel comfortable to of course
but just a little bit about yourself a
founded eco-wave power at
24 recognized by wired magazine as one
of the females changing the world
by fast company is one of the world's
most creative people in business
and with the winner of the united
nations global climate action award
ina i i can't even imagine what it takes
to get
to to to the level of to to this
amazing a contribution and i'm i'm
really
looking forward to hearing that in the
next 20 minutes but can you perhaps take
me back
all the way to this occurrence that you
had as a newborn
and and what happened there and how did
that sort of transform
your your life and your mindset into
where you are today
yes so i live in israel but i was born
in ukraine on
the 11th of april 1986 and two weeks
after i was born the chernobyl nuclear
uh reactor exploded and it was on the
26th of april
and it was the worst in history nuclear
disaster in terms of costs and
casualties
and many adults and children got a heart
problem respiratory problems
cancer and even death because of as a
direct
result of the explosion and i was one of
the babies that got hurt from the
negative effects of such explosion
i actually had a respiratory arrest and
a clinical death
and my mother just approached my creep
she looked down and she saw me pale and
blue and not breathing and
she freaked out she ran to my dad and
she said like oh my god oh my god my
baby is dead what do i do
and he shook her physically and said
you're a nurse do something
and then she remembered that she's a
nurse and gave me a mouth-to-mouth
resuscitation which actually saved my
life until the ambulance came
and obviously i don't remember all of
this i was a baby
but i grew up and my parents kept
telling me these stories so i felt wow
like i got a second chance in life i
should definitely do something special
with it i have a purpose
and i throughout my whole childhood and
early adult life
i was looking for like an amazing
purpose that could really make my second
chance you know important and worthwhile
so what is it like growing up you know
having this
pretty much death experience as a baby
you're getting resurrected by your own
mother and nurse and
i i can't think of many crazier stories
that i've ever heard than the one that
you just told me but what do you what
how
when does it actually become a part of
you this idea that i had
i'm giving a second chance at life i'm
gonna make the most out of it and i'm
not just for myself but i'm gonna do
something that
is going to make a direct impact on the
world is that also you know as you're a
kid or does that only formulate later on
so as a kid i i felt special you know i
felt like okay it's out of the ordinary
my
kind of background story and i did feel
that i want to do something special but
obviously
i didn't have enough information or
knowledge in order
in order to know at a young age what
really i would like to pursue
so when growing up when we moved to
israel from ukraine and we moved to a
very small town
called ako so it wasn't very
back then there was not even cinema or a
shopping mall in the city the city was
like kind of
just starting let's call it like that so
as a kid
i dreamed of maybe becoming a politician
because i thought that through politics
that's my best chance to kind of make
a positive impact on the world and
that's why when i went to haifa
university to study
i chose to study political science and
english literature with the hope of
becoming this great politician
which would really have an impact on
people's life
but when i finish the university
and i'm sure that some students can
relate with it i didn't have a lineup of
politicians that are waiting to hire a
political science major benjamin
netanyahu was not knocking on my door
and so i said to myself okay like i'm
older already i finished university
like you know i need to go to work and
uh i look at i looked at the famous job
search
website in israel and there was a there
was like a
an ad that is looking for a hebrew
hebrew
english translator at a renewable energy
company
and i worked there for one year it
wasn't really my cup of tea but
i did discover that the whole world of
renewable energy i discovered every
solar energy and wind energy and wave
energy and what really drew me to wave
energy specifically
is that solar and the wind energy were
already like commercialized
industries you had many companies
developing many different technologies
and like
it was already there it was already
existing and wave energy all the
engineers and all the scientists
they really were trying to develop
something
viable and commercially you know
commercially viable
and no matter how much money was
invested and how much effort was put
into it
they really couldn't make it work so
being you know an israeli with what we
call hutzpah
i said okay i'm from a little town i
have no money no contacts and no
technical background
but i can make it hap i can make it
happen
and that was kind of the beginning of my
passion
where i started really researching about
the wave energy
and did we forget to mention that you're
24 at this point
yes so when uh when i established eco
with power
together with my business partner david
level was that 24 years old
now that that's that's fascinating and
that mindset this shift i had no idea
that you went to study political science
and
and you know i i bet that when you
decided that that's what you're going to
study
you you don't imagine that one day the
united nations is going to crown you as
global climate action award winner and
so
take me take me through this
understanding that you have
you're 24 you're starting this you're
starting this company you have a
business partner
what is the thesis what is this you know
revolutionary aha
idea that you have that says i think i
know how to make a big impact
so you don't really know when you're
starting that
i'm gonna make a big impact you're just
kind of following your passion and
i really felt passionate towards this
field i really researched it
uh i saw what was the problem of all the
larger companies that were trying to
develop wave energy solution
i understood that the main problem was
in the fact that they're trying to go
offshore four or five kilometers into
the sea
so then it becomes super expensive you
need sheets you need divers you need
underwater moorings and underwater
cables
uh it breaks down all the time because
in the offshore you have wave heights of
20 meters and even
higher and unfortunately no man-made
stationary equipment can survive the
loads
it wasn't insurable and it wasn't
environmentally friendly
environmentalists which were supposed to
be the greatest supporters
and proponents of wave energy were
actually objecting it because it created
a new presence on the ocean floor which
disturbed the marine environment
so i kind of understood that in order to
have a commercially viable product we
need to solve this for problems
but again as i said before i did not
have the financial resources i did not
have uh
really the obvious uh in order to make
it happen and
in a social event i met my business
partner david lev who is a serial
entrepreneur
and when he just sat next to me and we
didn't he didn't know who i am i didn't
know who he is
and he asked me just like what's your
passion and i said wave energy and it
turned out that his passion was also
wave energy
and because he invested a lot in real
estate and one of his investments was a
surf camp a self-hotel in panama
so he was sitting there watching the
power of the waves and thinking wow
there must be
something better that you can do with
wave power other than you know sports
and surfing
so when i said to him like the same
thing he was research researching about
him
completely different you know area of
the world it was like
it was like it's meant to be and that's
what's really the birth and the
beginning of the eco-waste power
okay so the the beautiful you know a
childhood background even more beautiful
partnership with your with your business
co-founder but what how do you get to
then you know
securing this this pipeline of 254
megawatt i don't even know if i'm
reading this correctly because
i need to learn so much more about this
but what was this project what what is
the impact that eco-wave power actually
has
and what is the solution that you're
actually providing
so basically we developed a solution
that is solving the four main problems
that i've mentioned before
instead of going to the offshore far
into the sea we install an existing
man-made structure such as break water
spears
jetties and other types of structures we
basically attach floater to the external
side
of the marine structure of the break
water and these floaters are going up
and down with the movement of the waves
they're pushing a hydro cylinder which
transmits biodegradable fluid into land
located accumulators
a pressure is between the accumulator
the higher the waves the higher the
pressure
and this is used to turn the hydromotor
which is turning the generator and goes
to the grid via inverter
the whole system is controlled by a
smart automation system
and when the waves are too high for the
system to handle the floaters
automatically rise
above the water level and they stay in
the upward position
until the storm presses very similar to
wind turbines when the wind is too
strong the wind turbine actually
stops turning so we basically just again
we made it a bit
the israeli way it's very very simple
not a lot of moving parts
like smart automation smart software but
very simple hardware
because you don't want something
complicated in the marine environment
so i think this is really what we did
correctly
and and how do you get to them securing
this incredible project i don't even
know what
what that number that i said means this
256 megawatt pipeline but
how does that happen so it happens
step by step you know we started first
of all we had an idea but we didn't know
if the idea even
is feasible so we took an engineering
team and the engineering team really
made the calculation and the blueprints
and everything that is necessary to go
to the next step
our next step was doing a wave pool
testing you know to check kind of in a
controlled environment a controlled
environment to check the workability of
the technology
we did it in the hydro mechanical
institute of kiev in ukraine
and because we could save costs by doing
so
when we received approval from the
institute for the workability of the
technology and recommendation to enlarge
it to greater sizes
we did an off-grid power station in the
port of jaffa in israel that worked
between 2014 and 2020
so then people came to the power station
and says wow like it doesn't break down
and it's really cost efficient and we
see it's insurable and environmentally
friendly
but can you connect to the grid and then
in 2016 we opened our first grid
connected power station which was in
gibraltar still operational in gibraltar
and it was the first time we attempted
to actually connect with the grid
and since then when we really felt
comfortable with the
you know that we have a strong basis for
the technology and that we already had
the grid connected experience
we started contacting suitable ports or
breakwaters owners and they started
and governments and municipalities and
ports started contacting us because
they thought to themselves look we have
these huge breakwaters it's not prime
real estate
actually the breakwaters are also not
very environmentally friendly you put
cement in the water and obviously that's
not really natural but you have to do it
to protect the coastal populations and
the port so you take this unused
structure that is just used for
you know breaking the waves and you turn
it into something good you turn it into
a source of clean electricity
a source of revenues for the board a
place where you can
create employment opportunities in a new
green energy industry
so that's how kind of our commercial
rollout started we're just in the
beginning of the commercial rollout
we're not yet as let's say
as implemented as solar or as wind but
they also started many many years
you know before us so we're a new
technology and really my dream and hope
is
that in the future and we will see wave
power installed on
every breakwater in the world and even
the new breakwaters that are just being
planned
will already incorporate in the planning
stage wave energy into them
so how does the actual wave energy
compare
in its in its impact and sustainability
to solar and wind for example how big of
a deal is this going to be a part of the
world
you know obviously we can both agree
that the world will be green
one day or another it's gonna happen at
some point maybe it's a hundred years
from now maybe it's 30 years from now
but my question is you know from your
perspective how big of a role is
is wave power because i haven't heard
too much about wave power until now
and that's why i was also so excited to
hear about it because i'm just starting
to try to understand and we need to do
many more episodes for me to truly
understand
what's happening yeah so wave power is
an immense
source of electricity of clean
electricity according to the world
energy council
wave energy can actually produce twice
the amount of electricity that the world
produces now
now the clear advantage of waste power
except
yeah the clear advantage is that
two-thirds also of the work population
is living on the coastline
so with this type of population
distribution the need for wave energy is
undeniable you can save a lot of the
transmission costs
by just bringing the energy from the
coastline to the houses to the
population
other than that wave energy in suitable
locations can operate around the clock
24 7 day and night as opposed to solar
energy
that of course in the night you cannot
produce any electricity
but although really my passion is wave
energy
i don't think that one type of renewable
energy technology is the solution for
the world's problems
i really think that we need to combine
all renewable energy sources if it's
waves if it's solar if it's wind if it's
tidal
all of the sources will be the answer to
the world's problem
and will be able to provide 100
renewable energy
electricity to the world and that's why
i really believe that
all of us we should work together and we
should support each other
in order to have you know in each
country you have different prevailing
sources some countries don't have sun
but have a lot of wind or a lot of wave
and some countries are vice versa so
basically
everybody needs to work together in
order to enable the world to become 100
environmentally friendly because really
that's the future of our children
and what needs to happen so what is what
is the big problem is it the fact that
the technology
is a little premature still is it the
fact that governments aren't
and aren't experienced enough and when
they when they're installing these new
break waters
you're saying here rightfully so you
know we're installing new break waters
every day
they should be already integrated with
this with collecting the electricity
but you also need to go back and fix all
the ones that we already have and i'm
guessing there's millions of them around
the world right
yeah there's a lot uh there's many many
unused breakwaters of course in every
place where there's a sea or an ocean
which is way he
you would put a breakwater to protect
the coastal population
i think that the main problem or what
makes it a bit difficult
to reach full commercial rollout is the
fact that whereas
we are in a very high technological
readiness stage in terms of the
technology so we can build it pretty
fast and the technology is modular
and governments and the policy uh
setters they basically just now starting
to learn about wave energy like
throughout the years they saw all these
big offshore experiments that have been
made that have failed that have broken
down that have cost like tremendous
amount of money
and they thought to themself okay wave
energy is nowhere near commercialization
so why would we spend our time in
setting policy
or regulatory frameworks right or
legislation or anything
so then now what happens is that
actually we do feel comfortable with our
technology and we do feel that we can
make it happen
and our construction time is not that
long you know for a small station it can
be as little as six months
for a large station is 24 months but
still it's not a lot of time
but really what kind of uh impedes us or
slows us down
is the fact that that let's say a port
approaches us and they say we want your
wave energy technology and we say great
your port is really suitable we want to
install it there
what are what's the steps like which
kind of licenses do we need to do what
do we need to submit
and then the court says we don't know
like there's no regulation there's no
policy how to connect to the grid
how to connect to the breakwater and
that kind of kind of slows us down
uh i will say on a positive note that
wind and solar energy
went through the same route when they
started there were were also no
tariffs and no policies and no
frameworks for the implementation of
those technologies so when you knew
of course it takes time for most
countries to get familiar and to set the
policy
but it is a shame that we can build it
so fast and the ports and
coastal municipalities and the coastal
countries are really interested and what
slows us down
is like paperwork you know that's
something that's really burning in me
like i want to do more build more and do
it faster and like sometimes i feel that
i'm being like
slowed down by you know not so relevant
we need many many more people like you i
i'm leaving this conversation with
you know tingles i'm like and i'm so
inspired and
i already want to set a date for another
episode that we're going to do
for the show because i just love your
outlook i love your passion i love your
your understanding of things
and your directness that it's you know
you're saying it as it is and i just
love it completely
you know so thank you folks first of all
very much for coming here and sharing
this with me
20 minutes go by way way too fast and i
have three
fun yet crucial questions i must ask
first one is what was your favorite
subject in school
so i really like to study
bible for some reason i really like the
stories and the anal
thing of the you know the historical
events and i actually had the highest
grade in school in uh you know uh
in the in sixth grade probably i had the
highest score out of all the
other subjects i really enjoyed it i
think we had a great teacher that knew
how to
you know amazing explain it and talk
about it so
by the way sports was my least favorite
i'm beautiful and now
one of your role models who is one of
your role models
so i really like the personal life story
of jack ma
because his life story really emphasized
that you should never give up
and jack my very famous that he was
rejected from kfc
like they didn't even want to enable him
to sell
chicken and he tried to
go to harvard a number of times and he
was rejected from there as well
and he was a school teacher and he went
to work at an industry like he didn't
have any expertise in e-commerce
but he still was able to establish one
of the largest
websites in the world for that like
although kind of life kept telling him
no
no no in different you know routes that
he
tried to take he still never gave up and
was really persistent
and that's something that i really
appreciate
i i love it and the last question which
is not the most important one but it's
another interesting one three words you
would choose to describe yourself
i think passion like
you know as an entrepreneur you have a
lot of ups and a lot of downs and
you know i always say that it looks like
when you're having a heart attack and
they're showing you your
cardiac you know the
how it's called cardiogram and
it's going up and it's going down so
that's the life of an
entrepreneur so you really really need
to have passion and i think
i'm really like excited and passionate
about what i'm doing which really helps
me
along the laws too persistent
like again i had many difficult
again i opened the company when i was 24
i didn't have the
technical expertise i didn't have the
funding i didn't have the contacts i
grew up with a very small
city in israel called ako so really like
if i wouldn't
you know persisted persistent at what
i'm doing
then it wouldn't happen and we couldn't
establish and accomplish what we've
accomplished so far and i think also the
third thing is probably a creativity
and because many times when you're
working at a
very new industry and uh you know
people kind of don't know what you're
talking about you you definitely have to
take a creative approach
to explaining things to achieving things
and so on so
i think this is the first time i i love
it thank you very very much gina i
appreciate your time so so much
uh i kind of look forward to continue
following what you're doing with your
company
and helping the world be a better place
literally so thank you and stay safe and
stay healthy
thank you very much